it was a time when Israel's economy was
more famous for oranges and agriculture
than anything else
course now it's most well known for its
high technology industry case in point
this used to be a green house for
growing mushrooms this used to be a
tractor workshop there now both R&D labs
for one dog Moran he is Israel's
inventor of the USB stick and arguably
the country's most famous innovator I've
come here to this farming cooperative
just north of Tel Aviv to see what he's
up to now he's not flashy but his best
inventions are one of the first products
we develop is a flashcard
we're very excited fastest in a market a
huge capacity like one megabyte one make
nothing of a megabyte yes this is back
in a 1990s way it went public we went
public with revenues of 2.7 million
dollars
we had another product for this country
which the name day the name in the world
is known as USB stick actually I'm the
inventor of the USB stick this is a
stoical device because this is the first
news mystic that was brought to the
market it was a global hit his next bet
wasn't her mother was a great concept
model at home but surely this minus one
in the world alas even a funky charging
station couldn't save modu from the
all-conquering iphone it flopped how
does it work doves main focus today is
comigo a set-top box that makes dumb
televisions smart he also has a new
consumer product which looks
suspiciously like a USB stick you plug
it into the HDMI port of the TV and now
you can have it games and more video
channels and value-added services Duff
says money doesn't motivate him a
position perhaps helped by the hundred
million dollars he bagged from the sale
of M systems they're not looking to tiny
richest guy in the world or even in
Israel what I want to do is 22 in value
mostly they say amazing people I'm
working with make this world focus bring
progress make it better and I'm ready to
die with real money my car that seems
unlikely
if Dobbs doesn't also companies some
might fail the
don't bet against him picking another
big winner Elliot got chem Bloomberg
Israel